-Facebook has had
an absolutely disastrous week,
with a damning whistleblower
interview on Sunday,
an unprecedented outage
on Monday,
and then a Senate hearing
yesterday
on how the company
dismantled safeguards
and fostered a business model
where dangerous misinformation
can spread.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
Things have not been going great
for the world's most powerful
social-media platform.
On Sunday a whistleblower
who filed complaints
against the company
with federal law enforcement
revealed herself on "60 Minutes"
and said the company
is aware of the harm it causes
and prioritizes profits
over safety.
On Monday, Facebook
and its family of apps,
including WhatsApp
and Instagram,
suffered unprecedented outages.
And on Tuesday,
the same whistleblower
testified before Congress
and said the company's products
harm children
and hides what it knows
from the public.
Suffice it to say, Facebook
has had a [bleep] week.
It's the kind of week you'd
normally post about on Facebook.
Facebook had a worse week
than the Yankees
or, worse yet, Yankees
radio announcer John Sterling.
-The pitch to Stanton.
There it goes.
Deep left.
It is high, it is far.
It is gone out of the ballpark.
A Stantonian home run.
Now, what did I do wrong?
What did I see wrong?
He's at first base.
-Look, sports broadcasting
is hard,
and I also thought
it was gone off the bat,
but why did he keep going after
the ball bounced off the wall?
"It is high, it is far,
it is gone.
Stanton hit it so hard,
he stopped at first base,
taunting the Red Sox,
as if to say,
'I will finish my home run trot
when I am good and ready.'
What did I do?
What did I see?"
I'm sorry, but I just had to
make some time tonight
to indulge some
Yankee schadenfreude.
Plus, someone needs to
take Wally down a peg.
He's such a big Yankees fan,
he wears 27 World Series rings.
-That's right --
10 on my fingers, 10 on my toes,
and seven on my --
-No!
No, I do feel a little bad
making fun of Wally
on a day like today, until
I remember he is a Yankees fan
and a Patriots fan,
i.e., pure evil.
You know what his
least favorite team is?
The run that has to win
to save the orphanage.
So just be happy that the only
Wally smiling last night
was this guy.
Anyway, the massive
Facebook outage on Monday
was the company's worst
since 2008,
leaving its 3 billion-plus users
across the world in the dark
while it tried to figure out
what the hell was going on.
-Six hours later,
Facebook and Instagram
finally back online tonight,
the longest worldwide outage
ever to hit the company
and its more than
3 billion users.
The crash impacting businesses
who depend on the apps
to reach its customers.
-Now, for many small businesses,
Facebook serves
as their website,
their way to share their hours
and any updates
about their businesses.
Especially in India,
Latin America, and in Africa,
Facebook, in a lot of ways,
effectively functions
like the mobile Internet.
-Look, in certain countries,
Facebook is almost a utility
and it does provide
essential services,
linkages around the world.
-And it is, to say the least,
not good
that what amounts to
a global public utility
is controlled by one massive,
secretive international
conglomerate.
It's like finding out that all
the drinking water in the world
is controlled by some company
called AquaBuds
and it's run by
one weird little dude
who created the company
out of revenge
because none of the cute girls
at his college
would give him a glass of water.
"Oh, I'll show them.
I'll show them all.
Who's thirsty now, Courtney?"
Facebook has since explained
the outage, sort of.
They did so in
the vaguest way possible.
Using as much tech gobbledygook
as they could,
a Facebook executive said
the outage was caused by...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Explain it to me
like I'm a Facebook user.
Okay, I get it now.
Look, phrasing like "backbone
routers" and "data centers"
lead me to believe that
even when a company
as big as Facebook goes down,
they still have to deal with
Time Warner for some reason.
"Yeah, so leave it unplugged
for 20 seconds
before plugging it back in.
All right, I'll try it."
Anyway, the point is
that no one company
should have this much power --
not just one company,
one person,
because as whistleblower
Frances Haugen
explained
at yesterday's hearing,
there is one person
who very much calls the shots
at Facebook.
-Mark holds a very unique role
in the tech industry
in that he holds over 55% of all
the voting shares for Facebook.
There are no similarly
powerful companies
that are as
unilaterally controlled,
and in the end,
the buck stops with Mark.
There's no one currently holding
Mark accountable but himself.
Mark has built an organization
that is very metrics-driven.
It is intended to be flat.
There is no
unilateral responsibility.
The metrics make the decision.
Unfortunately,
that itself is a decision.
And in the end, if he is the CEO
and the chairman of Facebook,
he is responsible
for those decisions.
-The buck stops with him.
-That's right --
The buck stops with him,
which is, I guess, why, when he
goes out, he wears a disguise.
Either he's wearing
too much sunscreen
or his face is at home
recharging.
I knew there were funny clowns
and sad clowns,
but I didn't know
there were neutral clowns.
"I made you a balloon animal."
"Oh, what kind of animal
is this?"
"It is the double helix,
representing a DNA molecule,
so really it could be
any animal on Earth.
Happy birth anniversary day."
Haugen claims that Zuckerberg
made the choice
to run the site
based on the metrics alone,
which, if true,
is itself a massive choice.
You don't get to dodge
responsibility by saying,
"It's not me promoting
anti-vax misinformation.
It's a math equation."
The rest of us don't get to
show up to work three hours late
and say, "It's not my fault
Waze told me the fastest route
was kayaking up the East River.
I ran aground on a dead mobster.
Oh, Jimmy, why'd you have to
talk to the cops?"
So if the buck stops
with Zuckerberg,
what was he doing as
a whistleblower came forward
with damning allegations
that his company
was knowingly harming people
for profit?
-As this whistleblower
came forward this week,
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg
was posting video
of his sailing trip
as his company
faced a firestorm.
-The hearing also took stark aim
at Facebook's CEO,
Mark Zuckerberg, who posted
a video sailing with his family
on Sunday
just before Haugen exposed
some of the company's research
on children
in an explosive
"60 Minutes" interview.
-Side note -- I don't know
how this guy's always outdoors
with his complexion.
If I spend five minutes
on the beach,
I end up with sand in
every orifice for three days
and a sunburn on my taint.
I don't know how.
I do know if you go to Walgreens
and ask the pharmacist for help
with a sunburnt taint,
they kick you out of the store,
which, if you ask me,
"taint" polite.
But that's definitely
where you want to be
when a whistleblower accuses you
of manipulating people
for profit -- sailing.
What's the matter, you couldn't
find a dressage horse?
"I take issue with the fact that
you're criticizing our company."
Then on Tuesday,
Zuckerberg emerged
to respond to the claims
from Haugen.
And suffice it to say
his rebuttal was not that great.
-Zuckerberg writes...
-You don't know a tech company
that sets out to build a product
that makes people angry
or depressed?
What about Adobe Flash Player?
Gen-Zers won't know
what I'm talking about,
but it used to be
anytime you wanted
to watch something
on the Internet,
like a dancing baby
or a funny chipmunk,
you had to update something
called Adobe Flash Player
that you didn't
even know you had.
And it sucked
because it took forever
and you had to do it every time.
And even
the error message said...
Or how about Twitter?
Angry and depressed
is their whole business model.
I have a Klonopin
set aside every night
for my pre-bed doom scrolling.
I have specific accounts
I check every day
just to get pissed off.
When you used to log on
to Twitter, the bird whistled,
and now it just curses at you.
-[Bleep] you.
[ Tweets ]
-Also, you think
advertisers care
if the content people
engage with the most
is angry and depressing?
Advertisers just want eyeballs.
If they only wanted happy people
to see their ads,
they sure as hell wouldn't
put billboards in Times Square.
Times Square's
the only place on Earth
you can hear Elmo call a kid a
dip[bleep] in a Russian accent.
[ Russian accent ] No tickle me.
I tickle you.
Elmo tickle you.
[ Normal voice ] There's nothing
advertisers love more
than commercials
during sports games.
Those make people more angry
and depressed than anything.
Is Budweiser worried Wally's
never gonna drink it again
just because one of their
commercials played
after Aaron Judge
was thrown out at home?
I'm sorry, Wally.
-Actually, Seth,
I don't drink Budweiser.
-Oh, because of the commercial?
-No, because I get paid per line
on this show.
I only drink champagne.
-[ Laughs ] Oh!
Audiences are coming back,
Wally, and the party's over.
[ Laughs ]
So Zuckerberg likes to present
a glowing portrait
of what his platform does,
but in reality what Facebook
hides from the public
it's much more revealing,
as CNN explained this morning.
-Facebook released these numbers
for the second quarter of 2021
sort of painting a rosy picture
that showed the best-performing
links and posts on the platform
were about nice things
like your pets and cooking
and family outings
and things like that.
But some people started to ask,
"Well, what did quarter one
look like?
What did the first quarter --
the first three months
of this year look like?"
And it eventually --
That report,
which Facebook
chose not to release,
was leaked to
"The New York Times,"
and it showed one
of the top-performing links
on the platform in
the first quarter of this year
was a piece undermining
the vaccine.
-They hid that report
from the public,
but even if
it didn't eventually leak,
you don't need to be a data
analyst to know that Facebook
can be a toxic stew
of conspiracy nonsense,
and that's part
of the business model.
Just talk to your weird uncle
about the news.
"Are you getting the vaccine,
Uncle Ron?"
"Well, I read on Facebook
that it has a microchip in it
that turns your penis
into a Wi-Fi hotspot,
so I'm 50/50."
No corporation,
let alone a single individual,
should have this much power
over how we communicate,
which is why progressives
like Bernie Sanders,
Elizabeth Warren,
and Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez
have been calling
for a while now
to break up these giant
tech monopolies.
-I think we need vigorous
antitrust legislation
in this country,
because you are seeing --
you name the area,
whether it's pharmaceuticals,
whether it is Wall Street,
whether it is high tech,
fewer and fewer
gigantic corporations
owning those sectors.
Facebook has un-- I mean,
we deal with it every day.
They determine who
we can communicate with.
They have incredible power
over the economy,
over the political life
of this country,
in a very dangerous sense.
-Anybody in here
a little worried
about how Facebook
uses your data?
[ Crowd cheering ]
Yeah, just a little bit worried.
So some of you may know,
there was another company
that came along, WhatsApp,
and they said,
"We're going to offer you
a lot more data privacy.
That's going to be a part
of our sales pitch here,"
and, boy, they started
getting customers.
So Facebook had a choice.
Facebook could, A,
get better on privacy
or, B, they could just buy out
the competition.
What did Facebook choose?
Just buy out the competition.
No.
Giants are not allowed
to buy out the competition.
The competition has to be given
a chance to thrive, grow,
and either the giant gets better
or the giant dies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whenever Warren
goes into teacher mode,
it makes me wish she'd been
my driver's ed instructor.
Then I'd know
how to parallel park.
"Who here thinks you're
supposed to go in headfirst?
Well, you're wrong.
You want to pull in backwards
at a 45-degree angle
toward the curb.
And if you don't use
your turn signal,
so help me God,
I will fail you."
No company should
have this much power,
which is why progressives
have been calling for years
to break up Facebook
and other tech giants.
If the testimony we've heard
this week is correct,
Facebook knows what it's doing
is dangerous,
no matter how much they play
innocent and say...
-What did I do wrong?
-[ Laughs ]
"Is it my eyes?
My ears?"
This has been "A Closer Look."
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses.
They need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.